- This year, I've gotten
really into pro football.
Maybe it's getting to host the
"NFL Honors," I don't know,
or the fact that literally
every human that surrounds me
is obsessed with the game.
But I now am very into it,
and our next guest is one
of the voices of the game.
You can see her hosting
throughout the season
on NFL Network.
Say hello to MJ Acosta!
(upbeat rhythmic music)
(audience cheering)
(audience cheering continues)
(upbeat rhythmic music ending)
So excited you're here.
- Likewise.
- Like I just got into it, okay?
- (laughing) I know.
- Like really into...
Like, I'm in fantasy football too.
- Same, I have two leagues, it's too much.
- Oh, I'm gonna have more than one, yeah.
I... I...
(MJ gasping)
- That's an undertaking,
that's a commitment.
- It is an undertaking-
- Yeah.
- But you get so much joy,
and you actually start to
learn about the other teams.
- [MJ Acosta] 100%.
- 'Cause I used to just
only care about the Cowboys.
- (laughing) Well,
which is fair, I get it,
it's America's team.
I will say-
- Thank you for saying
it, and not me, okay.
(everyone laughing)
- Being part of fantasy football
is like my sneaky trick as a sportscaster
to make sure that I'm
up on every single game
across the entire league.
Because you're invested, you're in it,
you get upset when you lose.
Which in one of my leagues, I'm abysmal,
and the other one, I'm crushin' it.
So, you know,
multiple leagues does help
with the self-esteem a little.
- Yeah.
So wait, you started in broadcast
while a pro cheerleader,
which I didn't actually know that.
- [MJ Acosta] Yeah.
- That's incredible, did you
do both at the same time?
- Like most things in my life,
I'm doing all the things
all the time, all at once.
Yeah, look at that.
It's so tremendous.
I was already a sportscaster
when I made the Miami
Dolphins cheerleading team.
Fun fact though,
I tried out five times to be
a Miami Dolphins cheerleader
before I actually made the team.
So tenacity, also a central theme.
- Yeah, yeah!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
I tried out in my, not to
age myself, in my early 20s.
It was a very long, tedious process,
made it so close every time.
So I decided, let's focus,
let's focus on the career path,
let's focus on other dance opportunities.
And even once I started my career,
I had this little tug at me,
"If I don't try this
at least one more time
while I still have flexibility
early on in my career,
I'm gonna regret it."
And sure enough, that
was the year I made it.
Huge advantage being on the sidelines,
watching the game develop
in front of me in real time,
being part of a franchise,
invaluable experience
that still helps me to
this day in my career.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's so cool!
- Yeah.
- I never really think about that,
but I think that's so cool that
yeah, you were on the field,
like getting that and hearing everybody.
- [MJ Acosta] 100%.
- Now, you can hear people
'cause every time, it's-
- [MJ Acosta] Now they're mic'd up.
- "Hey, here we go!"
- Yup.
You hear it all!
(audience laughing)
That's a good cadence.
- "Here we go!"
And it's like every time
he does the play, Dak,
every time, it's like a lot.
- It's deep in the diaphragm.
- Yeah, "Hey!"
It's every time.
You're gonna hear it now
if you're watchin' a game.
- You could be a QB-
- I love you, Dak, I love
you. (audience laughing)
So I love that you also talk about this,
you don't play down
your femininity at all.
- No, no.
- 'Cause I feel like a lotta women
feel like they do have to do that.
- 100%.
I think not only the industry,
and there are so many tropes.
And I think a big challenge
for me at the beginning
was because I was an NFL
cheerleader, which by the way
was one of the toughest
things I ever had to do,
it was so much discipline,
so much dedication.
It's one of the things
that I'm proudest of.
And many folks at the
beginning of my career told me,
"Yeah, you probably
shouldn't lead with that."
Why, when was the last time
you were on the sideline
of a game the entire time?
Remind me again?
I didn't think so."
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And beyond that, I think-
(audience laughing)
- Oh, I love you.
- I think you can...
(audience laughing)
(laughing) Thank you, Kelly.
- Yeah.
- I think being hyper-feminine, or not,
whether you're a tomboy,
wherever you are and how you are
is how you should arrive
every day to work.
And that's very hard in sportscasting,
it's very hard in just the
entertainment industry.
And I refused to sort of push
myself into this little box
that they were constantly
trying to shove me in.
It would be disingenuous, one,
and it would not serve
the folks who watch us,
who wanna see themselves reflected
and wanna see themselves
represented on the screen
or on social media.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So for me, it was very
important to remind folks
that I don't have to
strip away my femininity
to show you that I'm credible
and qualified for my job.
- Absolutely.
(audience applauding and cheering)
(audience cheering
drowning out MJ speaking)
- And you're the perfect
mentor, you love mentoring.
- Yes.
- And you're kinda the
perfect mentor to do that
'cause that is like what
people need to hear,
especially young women in this industry.
- [MJ Acosta] 100%, yeah.
- That's important to
you, right, mentorship?
- No question.
It's been one of the biggest parts
of now this stage of my career.
'Cause I think when I started out,
there were even fewer
women than there are now.
It has evolved a bit,
but we still have such a long way to go.
But there were even fewer
who were really there for you step by step
'cause when they started
out, they didn't have anyone.
So for me, it was very
important to break that cycle.
And I remember at the
Super Bowl, back in Miami,
which was such a beautiful
moment in my career,
to be there, and to show everyone around,
and to do these feature interviews-
- Great merch.
- We had-
- Just sayin'.
- It's fantastic merch-
- Yeah, it was great merch.
- The colors were phenomenal.
- Yes.
- We had a dinner,
myself and one of my colleagues
at the NFL League office
put together a dinner
called A Seat at the Table.
And the whole purpose of the
dinner was to create a pipeline
between the women who were
already in the industry
and the ones who were up next.
To have a direct face-to-face
connection and say,
"Okay, not only are we breaking
the door off the hinges,
no holding it open, we're
tearin' that thing apart,
but we're going to be there
with you every step of the way
so you know that you're not alone.
And no one understands the
challenges better than we do.
We're here to navigate
and help you through,
and hopefully make it a little
easier than it was for us."
- Yeah. And I think it's cool
too (audience applauding )
'cause women more involved too.
- Exactly that.
- We have a young, aspiring
sports analyst here,
and she also has no idea that MJ is here
and that MJ has a giant
surprise for her as well.
So MJ's gonna hide for a little bit,
and we're gonna bring her
out just at the right moment.
So I'm gonna say bye right
now, but see you in a second.
At 12 years old,
our next guest is the
ultimate football fanatic,
so I had to have her on.
She seriously doesn't
miss a single NFL game,
she notes every stat,
and rewatches key plays
endlessly just for fun
which is so cool.
But for her, football
is not just a passion,
she actually wants to make it a career.
So everybody welcome Allie.
(audience cheering)
Hello!
- [Allie] Hi. (laughing)
- So I'm recently in love with football,
so you're gonna know way more than me,
but I'm so excited about it.
(Allie laughing)
So wait, so what's your favorite team?
- My favorite team is
the Kansas City Chiefs.
- Oh, that's a good one. Okay,
they have great initials.
Yes, I like them.
(Allie and audience laughing)
No, mine's the Cowboys, I love the Cow...
Don't you look at me like that, girl!
(audience laughing)
I love them so much!
But no, I'm gonna say Mahomes,
is he one of your favorites?
- Yes, definitely one of my favorites.
- He's really good.
Yeah, I would say he's
pretty talented, yeah.
So wait, do you wanna make
football like a career?
- Definitely, absolutely, yeah. (laughing)
- And you wanna do like broadcasting,
like what do you wanna do?
- I feel like it can really
depend on each day, (laughing)
I kinda feel like I wanna
do something different.
I love watching the "New Heights" podcast,
the Kelce brothers.
I think they're great.
- Oh yeah.
They're hilarious, yeah.
- Yeah, I love them. (laughing)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So something like that,
like watching and analyzing the game,
and giving facts and background knowledge
to people who aren't the
biggest fans of football
or who don't know
football incredibly well,
just making it accessible.
- Me,
I love people like you, yeah.
And you inform us, yes,
that's why I love listening
to the commentators,
the analysts, like all
that because I'm new to it.
- Yeah.
- So it's a really cool thing
'cause then you get to bring
new people into the sport.
- Definitely, yes. (laughing)
- Yeah.
So I know that you're
early in your career path,
but we have someone here
who's as passionate about
sports broadcasting as you are.
So, she wanted to meet you
'cause she's very impressed.
So she's an Emmy-winning sportscaster,
and to us, she is a
whole lotta woman, y'all.
(exciting rhythmic music)
(audience cheering)
Okay, so say hello to MJ Acosta!
Look at her!
(exciting rhythmic music continues)
She said, "What?"
- Oh my gosh!
(exciting rhythmic music ending)
(audience cheering)
I think you're amazing. (laughing)
- Aw, I think you're amazing.
(Allie laughing)
- Y'all, have a seat!
- Yes, please!
- Oh my... Good surprise, good surprise?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Yeah?
(audience laughing)
She's doin' something you
might wanna be doin' later.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- What impresses you most about this one?
- Ugh, first of all,
I'm already a huge fan.
Another curlfriend,
we need more of us out here.
- (laughing) Yes.
- I think just the fact
that you love the game so much already.
You're already a fan of it,
but also an analyst at it too.
So even if you're not
on television, right,
the fact that you're in
it is already a huge step.
You're way more ahead
than I was at your age,
that's for certain.
But the fact that you
wanna bring this to folks
who may not understand the
intricacies of the game
and all the X's and O's,
that's what's missing.
That's the missing link.
So I love
that you're representing not
just the next generation,
but really such a big gap
that still need to be
served throughout the NFL.
So congratulations, you're crushin' it.
- Thank you so much.
- Of course.
- Absolutely.
You wanna tell her about
maybe an opportunity?
- So I wanna make sure
that you can continue-
- I love...
She can't hide her face.
- (laughing) I'm so confused.
- She can't. Your face, you
got gifts for days, I love it.
- I wanna make sure that you
can continue down this path
and that any opportunity you wanna follow,
so I want to offer you my mentorship.
We can have several
different Zoom sessions,
I can help you out with anything you want.
And next time that I'm in New
York, I want you to shadow me
and so you can see what
the day in life is like
in a sports setting.
- Oh my God.
Can I give you a hug?
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you so much.
- Of course, of course.
- Oh my God, I'm so looking
forward to this week,
just to be able to shadow her,
I think you're gonna love that!
What do you think?
- I'm so excited. (laughing)
- She's gonna do great.
- (laughing) I'm like I love it.
- Oh my God, I can't wait to
hear what it's like afterwards.
I'm kinda jealous, I wanna
shadow her too 'cause-
- I mean, Kelly can come too.
- Now, I'm newly obsessed.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Anyway.